STEVE: TESTING IS EMERGING AS
WOK OF BIGGEST ISSUES TO
CORONAVIRUS SO FAR, IF YOU PIECE
TOGETHER WHAT HAPPENED, IT CLEAR
THAT IT WAS BUREAUCRATIC
BUNGLING THAT CAUSED PROBLEM,
THE PRESIDENT, WHO IDENTIFIED
THAT PROBLEM AND INSIST INSISTED
FIXED AND PRIVATE SECTOR IS
FIXING IT.
IN JANUARY, CHINA PUBLISHED THAT
GENETIC CODE THAT WOULD ENABLE A
TEST TO BE BUILD WITHIN DAY GHTS
GERMANS BUILT ONE, W.H.O.
ADOPTED IT, AUSTRALIAN BUILT ONE
THAT WORKED.
OUR CDC BUILT THEIR OWN, IT
WITHIN OUT ON FEBRUARY 6.
ABOUT A MONTH AFTER THE GERMAN
TEST, BUT YOURS DID NOT WORK ON
FEBRUARY 12 IT WAS THE RECALL
HEAD, MORE TIME WENT BY,
UNIVERSITY LABS WERE BEGGING TO
MAKE A TEST, FDA, SAID, NO, AT
END OF FEBRUARY, WENT ON
PRESIDENT INTERVENED, RED TAPE
WAS SWEPT AWAY, LATER HE ORDERED
OVERHAUL OF TESTING APPROACH,
FRIDAY HE ANOUNCES A TESTING
PARTNERSHIP BETWEEN GOVERNMENT
AND PRIVATE SECTOR, BUT WHO WAS
RESPONSIBLE FOR INIT INITIAL DEL
WHO WAS RESPONSIBLE, THIS MAN
DR. HAHN HEAD OF FDA OR THIS 1
DR. REDFIELD, HEAD OF THE CDC,
WE NEED THE ANSWERS NOW SOMEONE
MUST TAKE RESPONSIBILITY, IF IT
WAS NOT YOU, TELL US WHO IT WAS.
THIS IS BUREAUCRATIC
BUNGLING-THE WORST TIME THIS
ALWAYS HAPPENS IN GOVERNMENT,
CIVIL SERVANTS NEVER TAKE
RESPONSIBILITY, NOTHING CHANGES.
JENNA.
>> I THINK THAT PRESIDENT TRUMP
ADDRESSED THIS VERY DIRECTLY
WHEN HE SAID THAT THEY WERE
TAKING DECISIVE ACTION AND THAT
THE VICE PRESIDENT SAID TODAY
THAT WITH THE FDA’S SWIFT
ACTION, NOW THERE IS A HIGH
THROUGH PUT FOR TESTING.
WE SHOULD FOLK US WHAT FOCUS ON
THAT WE HAVE, WITH LEADERSHIP,
USING THAT MAKING BEST DECISION
YOU WITH THE INFORMATION AND
RESORTS HAVERESOURCES YOU HAVE A
THAT IS WHAT PRESIDENT TRUMP IS
TAKING GREAT AND DECISIVE ACTION
HERE, LEADERSHIP BY EXERCISING
HIS WISDOM AND DISCRETION,
SAYING HERE IS WHAT WE’RE DOING
TO DO, SHE HE BEING FULLY
TRANSPARENT WITH THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE.
I THINK WE DO NEED ANSWERS, BUT
MORE THAN THAT, WE NEED TO FOCUS
ON FUTURE, AND FOCUS ON WHAT THE
FDA AND CDC ARE DOING
AT-THIS-POINT IN COORDINATION
WITH STATE AND LOCAL GOVERNMENT.
AND PRESIDENT TRUMP WAS SO
BRILLIANT TO BRING IN SPRY PRIVA
SECTOR, WALMART AND OTHERS CAN
HAVE TESTS IN PARKING LOTS,
WE’RE COMING TOGETHER AS A FULL
SOCIETY, BUT NOT SAYING WE HAVE
TO HAVE A LOCALIZED AND
CENTRALIZE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT WE
NEED TO GET EVERYONE INVOLVED.
STEVE: WHICH IS WHAT THEY ARE
DOINGDOEDOING.
YOU ARE BEING ERROR VERY KIND TO
BUREAUCRATS, MATT GAETZ WHAT DO
YOU THINK?
>> YOU HIGHLIGHTED WHAT IS A
PROBLEM IN WASHINGTON THROUGHOUT
THE ENTERPRISE OF GOVERNMENT,
PEOPLE INSIDE OF THE BELTWAY
WANT TO DRAW MORE POWER TO
WASHINGTON, PUSHING’S NATURAL
INSTINCT TO UNLOCK THE POTENTIAL
OF OURO COUNTRY TO SOLVE
PROBLEM, THAT IS WHY IN
BEGINNING THERE WAS A LOGJAM AT
CDC, PRESIDENT TRUMP OVERRULED,
SAYING WE NEED STATE BASE LABS
TOSO.
>> SO WHETHER IT IS THE ECONOMY,
OR THE ENVIRONMENT OR ANY OTHER
ISSUE, THE PRESIDENT’S INSTINCT
IS TO DEMOM RAHTIZE POWER, AND
JOE BIDEN SAID HE WOULD DO MORE
TO FEDERALIZE THE RESPONSE BUT
LEVERAGING OUR PARTNERSHIP IS
MORE EFFECTIVE.
STEVE: LISA YOUR TAKE?
>> IT -- WE’RE BEING HONEST THIS
IS THE BIGGEST POINT OF
VULNERABILITY FOR THE PRESIDENT,
THE FACT THAT WE HAVEN’T -- THE
SLOWNESS IN TESTING THAT IS AN
ISSUE FOR THE PRESIDENT.
IMPORTANT NOW THEY ARE RAMPING
UP EFFORTS AND INCREASING
ABILITY FOR TESTING THAT IS A
CONCERN, IF YOU LISTEN TO PEOPLE
LIKE DR. FAUCI SAY WE NEED TO
BLOCK SICK PEOPLE FROM GETTING
IN, WE’VE SEEN PRESIDENT TRUMP
TAKE ACTION WITH CHINA AND
EUROPE, AND THE U.K., HE GOT
CRITICISM FOR WITH CHINA.
EVEN FROM PEOPLE LIKE JOE BIDEN
WHO SAID IT WAS XENOPHOBIC, IT
WAS RIGHT THING FOR HIM TO DO,
OTHER COUNTRY FOLLOWED SUIT, BUT
ALSO MITIGATING SPREAD IN UNITED
STATES TO DO THAT WE NEED TO
KNOW WHO HAS IT.
I THINK WHAT IS IMPORTANT THAT
IS BEING DONE NOW, DRIVE THROUGH
TESTING, YOU LOOK.
ALMOST HALF OF CASES GEM GOT IN
A HOSPITAL.
IT IS IMPORTANT TO SEPARATE
PEOPLE WHO ARE POTENTIALLY SICK
WITH DRIVE-THRU TESTING, THAN TO
PUT THEM IN HOSPITAL THEN GET
ADDITIONAL PEOPLE SICK WHO DON’T
HAVE IT.
IT SHOULD BE RAMPED UP.
STEVE: I COULD NOT GET ANYONE TO
BITE FOR MY CALL TO NAME, NAMES